We finished off the
last video entering
into the Great Depression.
It wasn't just a
depression for the US.
It was a depression
for the world.
But I want to back
up a little bit,
because I forgot to mention
a very important fact that's
hugely important to
the rest of US history
into the 20th century.
And that's what happened in
1917, actually during World War
I. And that's the
Bolshevik Revolution.
The Russian empire was
overthrown by the Bolsheviks.
And it became the Soviet
Union, which you probably know
was a communist state, and
it became the United States
archenemy over the
rest of-- well,
not over the rest of--
but near the, I guess,
the second half of
the 20th century.
So with that out
of the way, I just
want to make sure you know that
Russia is now the Soviet Union.
Let's fast forward back
through the Great Depression,
and probably the
one point when we're
doing this very high-level
overview that's of interest.
And as you can see, even
though the focus of this series
of videos is on US
interest, what's
happening in the
rest of the world
is starting to become much more
important, because the US is
starting to become this
really serious global actor.
And so in 1933-- so this
is right in the middle
of this global depression,
and Germany was especially
hit hard because of all the
damage done by World War
I and the war reparations
and all the rest.
You have Hitler coming to
power as chancellor of Germany.
And it's interesting to
note that it was actually--
he came to power in
a democratic process.
Chancellor of Germany is
analogous to prime minister
of other countries,
and so essentially he
was ruling a coalition.
The Nazis, his party, did
not have the majority.
But they were able to
control this coalition.
Although it was a very weak one.
But what they were good at
is intimidating and rigging
elections and all the rest.
And so over the course
of the rest of the '30s,
essentially the Nazis
consolidated power
until we get to 1939.
And the rest of the world
would kind of watch Hitler.
He was consolidating power.
He came in democratically,
but he was essentially
consolidating power
under himself,
turning it into a dictatorship.
He was militarizing Germany.
People started to get
concerned, but they all
had the doctrine of appeasement.
Hey, you know, let's just
not make him too angry
and maybe he won't
start anything too bad.
But in 1939, Germany
invades Poland.
And this is kind of
viewed as the one event
that kind of-- the straw
that breaks the camel's
back, so to speak.
And so it begins World War II.
So this is the beginning
of World War II.
And initially it's
between-- I guess
if you think about the great
powers that initially get
involved, it is the British
Empire and the Soviet Union.
France is involved.
It quickly gets
overrun by the Nazis.
And what happens
is that the US-- it
wasn't like the situation
with World War I
where the US was
trying to stay neutral.
The US had recognized,
especially FDR, Franklin Delano
Roosevelt, he had recognized
that Hitler was an aggressor,
that he was, from FDR's point
of view, definitely in the wrong
here.
So even from the
beginning of World War II,
the US did help
support the Allies.
So it would send arms and
any other type of assistance.
When Japan and Italy joined
on the side of Germany,
the US embargoed oil to Japan.
The US was an exporter
of oil to Japan.
And you could
imagine Japan did not
produce a lot of its own oil,
and oil is super important
when you're trying
to run a war machine.
So that didn't make
Japan too happy.
So you fast forward to 1941,
and you have Japan bombing Pearl
Harbor.
So until this point, US kind
of played a non-direct role.
It definitely
supported the Allies.
It did what it
could economically
and by providing military
aid, but it did not actively
participate in the fighting.
But then December 7,
1941, the Japanese
bombed the US Pacific
fleet at Pearl Harbor.
And that's a whole
interesting debate
because, or discussion,
it was lucky for the US
that a lot of the Pacific
fleet was not there.
But it was obviously this thing
that convinced the US public
that World War II
was worth joining.
So in 1941, because of Pearl
Harbor, the US enters the war.
And it enters the
war in both arenas,
both in Europe and
in the Pacific.
And then you fast forward.
It goes against the
Italians in North Africa.
And then you fast forward
to 1944, it actually
enters into the fight
in mainland Europe.
This is the invasion
of Normandy.
This is D-Day.
June 6, 1944.
If you have ever seen
"Saving Private Ryan,"
it starts with this.
I've never stormed
a beach, but I
could imagine that's probably
the most realistic reenactment
of what it was like to
storm the beach at Normandy.
But you fast forward to 1945.
And eventually, especially
between the Soviet and the US,
or I should say all
the Allied forces,
they're able to, I guess, win
the European front of World War
II.
And then you fast forward
to the end of that year.
Japan was still kind of
fighting pretty ferociously.
And so the US-- and
this is once again--
I could make many
videos of this.
We can debate the ethical
implications of this.
But the US develops
the atomic bomb,
ignites one over Hiroshima
and then a few days later one
over Nagasaki.
And that essentially
ends World War II.
And so the outcome
of World War II
is you have two
remaining superpowers.
You have the Soviet Union, and
you have the United States.
And what happens after that
is that you have the Cold War.
These two huge powers,
the Soviet Union
is this communist country.
It's obviously trying to
create this communist sphere
of influence.
A lot of Eastern Europe was
falling under Soviet sway.
The United States, not
a communist country,
a very capitalist
country, you can imagine.
And this is something
that gets confused a lot.
The Soviet Union was communist,
and it was totalitarian.
Communism and Democracy
aren't necessarily things
that go against each other.
But the Soviet Union had
neither a capitalist system,
nor democracy.
It was both communist
and totalitarian.
And when I say
communist, I'm talking
about no private wealth.
The state really
owned all resources.
The United States, on the other
hand, was hugely capitalist.
And you could imagine many
people in the United States
did not want any of
this communism business
to come to us.
So you have this major battle
that never really erupts
into direct conflict between
the Soviet Union and the United
States.
It's always done
through proxies,
through people who the United
States or the Soviet Union
is acting on the behalf--
or who are acting on behalf
of the United States
or Soviet Union.
But you have the
Cold War beginning.
And it's called the Cold War
because it wasn't a hot war.
The United States
and the Soviet Union
never really fired
bullets at each other.
Instead, they
supported other parties
that would fire bullets
at the Soviet Union.
Or the Soviet Union would
support other parties
that would fire bullets
at the United States.
And for the United
States, it was all
about stopping communism.
It was all about preventing
this domino theory
that if one country in a
region would fall to communism,
that other countries would.
So the United States
became a bit paranoid,
or maybe it was justified.
Either way, it
was very concerned
about the spread of communism.
And the first time that this
really gets tested-- and 1950
is an interesting year, because
this is the first time--
obviously, the US had
nuclear weapons as of 1945.
But in 1950, the
Soviet Union tested
its first nuclear weapon.
So now the Cold War is
starting to get very serious.
Both of these
adversaries can now
nuke each other
if they wanted to.
And also in 1950,
you have Korea.
And Korea, before World
War II-- so that's
a very small
depiction of Korea--
it was a Japanese colony.
But obviously,
Japan had now lost.
And so after World
War II, it was
split between an area,
North Korea, which
was influenced by the Russians,
and South Korea, which
was influenced by
the United States.
And it was split along
the 38th parallel,
and I know this is a
super small diagram.
We'll go into more
detail when we
do detailed videos
about the Korean War.
But in 1950, you have the North
Koreans invaded the South.
So it started the Korean War.
The US sent troops.
The North Koreans had China on
their side, the Chinese army.
The Soviets were
also supplying them.
But at the end of
the day in 1953,
you fast forward,
it ends up being
a little bit of a stalemate,
because the end result was is
that the original 38th
parallel border gets,
I guess, reinstated.
But that was the first real
conflict of the Cold War.
And notice there were
never US or Russian--
or I shouldn't say Russian--
US or Soviet troops
directly firing at each other.
The US were at
war with the North
Korean and the Chinese
troops, but they
were kind of proxies
for the Soviet Union.
And at the same time,
as you can imagine,
because you have these
two adversaries, these two
technically sophisticated
adversaries--
they both had
nuclear weapons-- it
became very interesting on who
can kind of dominate space.
So you have this kind of
space race developing in 1957.
The Soviets are able to launch
the first artificial satellite
around the earth.
This is Sputnik One over here.
Some people think
the first Sputnik
is the one that
had the dog in it.
No, that came a
few months later.
That was Sputnik Two, actually.
Had the picture of the dog here,
but the dog eventually dies.
But it was alive for
a little bit in orbit.
So that gets
everyone freaked out.
The US responds.
Then in 1961 you
have Yuri Gagarin.
He's the first person in space,
first human being in space.
He returns safely.
We eventually get up there--
or the United States eventually
gets up there as well.
And you fast forward all
the way to 1969, the US
is the first to be on the moon.
So you have this space race.
The two countries are really
trying to one up each other.
And at the same time
that that's happening,
you have-- and I bring this
up just because so much
happened during his presidency.
In 1960, you have
John F. Kennedy
being elected kind of in
the heart of the Cold War.
And the other
interesting thing is
he was the first
Catholic president,
which people questioned.
That by itself was interesting.
But what was really interesting
in his short presidency-- and I
think you might know
that only had really--
he actually became
president in '61.
This is an error.
He was elected in '60, but
he became president in '61.
He had a very short presidency.
He was assassinated
in '63, but a lot
happened in that
short presidency.
In 1957, right before he became
president, you had-- oh, sorry.
Not 1957.
Let me get my years right.
1959 you had the
Cuban Revolution.
Cuba became communist.
Fidel Castro takes over.
It becomes communist.
So you could imagine,
the Americans
didn't like a communist state
so close to our own borders.
So in 1961 we support
some ex-Cubans,
or some Cuban exiles,
to try to invade Cuba.
And that also can be a whole
topic for another video.
There's debates between the CIA
and the Kennedy administration
for who was to blame for
it being such a failure,
but it was a failure.
So it was a huge embarrassment
to the United States.
And from the
revolutionaries' point
of view, the communist
revolutionaries' point of view,
they kind of viewed this as
solidifying their hold of Cuba.
It showed that
they could fend off
a counter-revolutionary assault.
And then you have in 1962.
We have these spy planes.
And we see that the
Soviets are starting
to put these ballistic missiles
in Cuba, which really freaks
the United States out, because
these ballistic missiles could
reach any part of
the United States.
We actually had similar ones
in parts of Europe and Turkey,
but we don't like
these things here.
So we essentially used
our Navy to, I would say,
blockade any more arms
shipments to the Soviet Union.
So Kennedy really has this kind
of stand-off with the Soviet
Union during the Cuban
Missile Crisis in 1962.
And most people
believe that this
was the closest that the United
States and the Soviet Union
ever got to actually
having a war,
and which would have probably
turned into a nuclear war.
But the stand-off
eventually got resolved.
The Soviet Union agreed
to remove their missiles.
Well, one, not send anymore
missiles and dismantle the ones
that they had already set up.
And this wasn't publicly
stated at the time,
but the United
States also agreed
to do the same thing
for our missiles
that were pointed
at the Soviet Union,
to remove those from Turkey.
So the world, at least
at that point in time,
had avoided a mutually
assured destruction.
The whole time that
this is happening,
remember, the United
States is paranoid.
And maybe justifiably so.
Paranoia usually means worried
when there's not a cause.
But maybe justifiably worried
about the spread of communism.
You have a situation
where, in Vietnam, you
have a Vietnam, which
is right about-- let
me make sure I circle the
right country-- you have
in Vietnam the communists come
to power in North Vietnam.
This was formally
a French colony.
The US, right from
the get-go in 1950,
start sending advisers to
aid the anti-communists
in South Vietnam.
In Kennedy's administration,
the amount of advisors-- and I
should probably
put that in quotes,
because these advisers started
becoming much more involved--
really grew.
And until 1965,
the United States
started sending it acts
actual official combat
troops to fight in Vietnam.
And you fast forward
that all the way to 1975.
And the reason why
this is significant,
other than this being one of
the more recent major wars
the United States
has been in, it's
the first war that the United
States kind of unambiguously
lost.
In 1975, the last presence
of the United States left.
And essentially
Saigon, which was
the capital of South Vietnam,
fell to the communists.
So I'll leave you there,
and we're now essentially
in modern history.
At least from my point
of view, because I
was born not too
long after that.
Anyway, hopefully you
found that interesting.
Let me, oh, I couldn't
find the stop button.
There you go.